alors la chloroquine est un médicament
qui a été très utilisé dans le
traitement du paludisme mais qui est
aussi utilisé dans beaucoup de maladies
inflammatoires actuellement avec des
doses beaucoup plus important est que
moi j'utilise depuis 30 ans pour traiter
des infections avec des bactéries
intracellulaires et pour lequel on avait
d'ailleurs suggéré que ça marcherait
aussi sur des virus et en pratique et
les gros virus qui sont dans les
cellules moi j'ai traité 4000 personnes
avec de la chloroquine qui avaient des
maladies bactériennes chronique circuler
maladie de whipple j'ai effectué des
milliers de dosage de la chloroquine
donc c'est un médicament que je connais
très bien et que je suis depuis très
longtemps pour les infections virales
mais a été démontré au laboratoire que
moins quatre espèces différentes de
coronavirus était sensible à la
chloroquine au laboratoire maintenant
très récemment les autorités chinoises
est un composé mixtes de chercheurs de
régulateur d'autorité ont rapporté les
résultats préliminaires d'une étude
portant sur plus de 100 balade avec la
moitié traités par la chloroquine et
l'autre moitié sans chloroquine en
rapportant que ça amélioré d'une manière
significative
l'évolution vers la pneumonie ou
s'améliorer les images radiologiques ça
permettait de réduire le temps
d'hospitalisation et plus récemment un
des chercheurs les plus connus de chine
faisons vient de dire que quand on était
sous traitement par chloroquine la durée
de portage du virus et théo aux
alentours de 4 jours donc ça diminue
probablement aussi la durée de portage
virus est celui qui rapporte ça c'est le
pin homologue chinois le plus connu au
monde qui ont appelé le héros du sart
ses ongles et maintenant ces
recommandations font partie des
guidelines de la république de chine
pour le traitement des pneumopathies
avec le nouveau corona renverrait
chinois donc sauf à dire que les chinois
ne savent pas travailler sont incapables
je peux pas faire autrement que de dire
que
les chinois ont dit ça et que comme
personne ne pourra démontrer que ça
n'est pas la meilleure solution parce
que personne autant de malades
eh bien il faut adopter cette solution
parce que c'est la meilleure pour les
patients compte tenu de l'état de
connaissances personnellement je ne fais
jamais de prédiction en particulier pour
les maladies nouvelles si vous voulez
dont on ne sait pas du tout comment elle
évolue
par exemple le tout le monde redoutait
que le sar ce2 se évolué vers une
pandémie mondiale et puis brutalement en
juillet 2003 ça s'est arrêté et puis il
ya plus de cas donc moi je ne fais
jamais de prophétie ce qui m'évite de
faire des fausses prophéties et donc je
ne sais pas ce qui se passera je pense
qu'il faut être vigilant attentif pour
l'instant en dehors de chine tout cette
activité a concerné 35 ans de chine
aujourd'hui en tout et pour tout dans le
monde ait eu 35 morts hors de chine avec
le corps navires chinois alors peut-être
que ça va devenir un désert c'est pas
sûr parce que beaucoup de coronavirus
sont saisonniers et donc disparaît
spontanément au printemps sans qu'on y
fasse rien donc les maladies
infectieuses c'est très compliqué et il
faut éviter
mon point de vue de faire des prévisions
sur 7 ces maladies parce que dans le
passé toutes les prévisions sur les
maladies émergentes se sont toujours
révélées fausses sans exception nous à
marseille pour pouvoir faire face à ces
crises épidémique puisque moi j'avais
été chargé de mission par le ministère
de la santé
certes à rechercher un peu moins de 20
ans pour savoir comment répondre aux
crises l'hôpital que nous avons fait la
situe au spi talents univercité avait
une des réponses aux crises qui
ressemble beaucoup d'ailleurs aux
hôpitaux qui avait été fait en chine au
lendemain du sart cinq mois j'avais eu
l'occasion de visiter à shanghai en 2005
et donc nous avons une capacité
d'absorption des affections réguler très
rapide surtout si nous confirmons ce que
les chinois ont trouvé c'est à dire que
la période après le début du traitement
où les gens sont porteurs de virus n'est
que de quatre jours
ça veut dire que la moyenne
d'hospitalisation sera de quatre jours
et nous nous avons 75 lits d'isolement
ce qui veut dire que le débit est de
plus de 100 par semaine ce qui est
beaucoup rien de chez nous donc chez
nous je peux parler de la situation
d'ailleurs je ne la connais pas